hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round seven of the
2019 sinful cup it's probably the most
awesome game ever played in the 2019
sing folk up in round 7 and I'm sure
gonna enjoy it let's just the dive
straight into it ding opens with the
white pieces and he opens with D for a
lot of we have already suggested this
game so I knew even before I saw that it
was a quite a special one we have c4 e6
and now not going into the Queens gambit
declined but the g3 dingos for the
Catalan opening with Bishop to b4 check
by Anand Bishop to b2 blocking and now
Bishop a back to e7 I with Bishop the
g-tube ending fee and care of the light
square bishop and the now d5 Knights the
f3 with castles by Anand castles by dink
and now Knight B to d7 and Queen to c2
just nicely developing and there is a
there are a few games in the database
for C for C if I was played but black
really didn't achieve much with that so
c6 here this is the main idea with a for
preparing to expand further would be
four so on done prevented with a five
and now Knight to a3 then follows the
same game that he already played in 2017
against the Boris Gelfand although in
that game Gelfand had the white pieces
and end the game contingent Knight to e4
this is what being played and dink want
a very nice game with the black pieces
but here on plays Bishop to d6 instead
with Knights the e1 and now again there
are two games where Queen to e7 was
played both of them were played by Boris
Gelfand
a one game against the popular Gianna
one against evgeny thomashefsky but here
aren't plays rook to e8 it's a new move
and it is from move 11 that we have a
completely new game with Knight the d3
now the knife controls nicely c5 sorry a
c5 and e5 with E 5 and here dink has to
decide whether he wants to trade on e5
or does he want to go into or ins a
nicely prepared line and the ding is not
afraid he says okay show me what you got
he plays C CAP for Sun d5 and Anand
place fee for pushing the knight back
with Knight to f4 and now comes
see captures on d5 also possible was
well after the night was attacked you
could try captures on c6 it involves a
peace sacrifice for example after week
after sandy 3 Queen captures be
character so you get Bishop captures on
c6 and now you have 3 points for the
peace after Ruby 80 you want to save the
roof Knight b5 and White gets a lot of
country play for his sacrificed PC 4 is
coming but it's hard to imagine
something like this would be played
without preparation in in modern chess
but ok after E 4 we have Knight to f4
biding and now see captors and e5 just
claiming an Isis Center for himself with
nice to be 5 biding and now of course
keeping the dark square Bishop with
Bishop to b8 tucking it in for later
rook 8 2 c1 now as the rooks are not
connected there's quite a lot of
pressure along the C file and now rook
the a600 prepares rook to c6 with Bishop
to h3 now the bishop is much more useful
on this diagonal and now rook the c6 as
planned the queen is under attack Queen
to b3 and now comes Knight to b6 now
preparing Knight to c4 really an
excellent move also opening up an attack
towards things like score Bishop but by
playing Knight to b6 Anand is also
saying yes you can capture on a5 which
will prevent me from playing Knight to
c4 as my knight will be pinned and this
is exactly one what's ding plays and
this is what makes the game so
interesting with bunch of capture Sunday
5 run plays Bishop captures an h3 Knight
captures an h3 and now on and just on
pins by quintus e8
opening up an attack against things
night here and also putting a lot of
pressure along the C file and here
capturing is not great if you capture
first you get B captors and now both the
knight and the knight on h3 are under
attack
so after let's say King G 2 now you
don't capture right away because you
lose your night here but now you play
Knight c4 and now white either loses
this night or this bishop so black black
is it would be winning here so after
Queen to c8 bingos for Kingi - just
defends the night here and now Anand
plays rook captures on C
and it means that Anand is out of his
preparation because there is a much
nicer move here
the move is Knight to c4 and here
obviously the engine gives this as
completely winning for black which is
why I use the quote above the board
someone suggested it if the engine likes
it then we should all like it
the bishop is under attack if you want
to save the bishop let's say play but
should be for now you get Knight to g4
just the c4 Knight energy for Knight are
now preparing III and well there's not
much you can do here for example Knight
G 1 you get III and now after f4 you get
Knights to d2 attacking the Queen
attacking the rook here after you
capture it sorry Bishop captures on d2
you get
eek a person D 2 now for threatening to
capture on c1 rook the c3 rook captures
on c3 Knight captures in c3 and now for
example Knight III check picks up picks
up material here and the white just
falls apart so Allen did not play Knight
to c4 here he played rook captures on c1
with rook captures on c1 and Queen
captures on c1 he decided to grab the
exchange with Bishop captures and b6 and
now III with f3 biding now that's a very
very strong pawn and now comes h5 Anand
wants to create more weaknesses with h4
with Bishop to a5 dink says it's very
important to bring this bishop over t1
from where it will nicely guard the g3
square with h4 and now first dink plays
G captures on h4
and now again we have a a very dynamic
position where you're more than welcome
to pause the video and find it the best
idea for black while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent spotter of crazy engine lines
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show again it was necessary to
give up something but only temporarily
Knight to e4 will be winning here now
you have to capture the night if you
don't capture the night you get nice to
d2 which comes with an attack on the
Queen and after that
Queen to f1 is just game over or after
night to be too bla white can capture it
but then you get this point over to d2
and there is no stopping black from
getting another Queen so you have to
capture the night then you get the rook
captures here and now after rook to g4
again it's all over for white now you
can try Knight c7 block the dark square
Bishop give give back some material but
even after Bishop captures Bishop
captures you'll get Queen captures on c7
now comes Queen to c3 you'll you you can
try and trade but Queen d7 and now the
queen is coming over here there's no
stopping no stopping mid or severe
material loss so Knights that evil would
have been winning here but Anand plays a
different light he plays Queen to c6 his
idea is he wants to move the Knights to
h5 and then bring the Queen over to g6
that'll ever check and continue the
attack but now Dean finds it Bishop to
e1 now the bishop can block the
influence of the b8 Bishop about playing
Bishop to g3 and again Anand is in time
to play Queen to see one with Queen to
c1 he again regains his winning position
because now Bishop to g3 doesn't work
due to Bishop captures H captures and
Queen - II won and there is no stopping
both Queen captures and a2
I need to also nice to h5 followed by
Queen to g3 is a deadly idea so ding
would have been lost here but Anand
hurried with his Knights to h5 idea
and now didn't just play Bishop to g3
and now the same the same thing no
longer applies
so here Anand said okay but a queen to
c4 here on and decided to trade Queens
as being now successfully defended with
Queen captures D captures and c4 and now
Knight to g5 so if you capture and g3
you're just gonna improve things pawn
structure so nothing to look forward to
there but what else is there unemployed
Knight to f6 and now we have Knights to
a3
going after the c4 pawn so uh ding is
down the exchange but he has a few extra
point with Bishop characters and g3
H captures and now rooked
going after the a for pawn with Knight
characters on c4 rook captures an a4 and
mountain Knight captures on e3 with rook
captures than before and now King to f2
starting to improve the position of the
King and now you can see that Anand is
still up the exchange but ding is up 2
points we have Knight to d5 and now
comes Knight to f5 declining the trade
and now preparing h5 and h6 we have rook
to be for going after the beat you pawn
and h5 s planned
we have rook a person B to enter now h6
so here if you capture you're gonna lose
both pawns so it's not something you
want to do this comes with check you're
gonna lose the f7 point as well
so after f6 we have knight back to e4
now G captures on h6 night characters
with check King f8 and now Knight back
to f5 so here blonde and still has a
past be pawn if he can start pushing it
he should be able to win this if if such
a thing is possible we'll be 5 on and of
course starts pushing it
we're Knights - III offering a trade and
night to b6 and declines the trade king
he won and now comes B 4 and here we
have king 2 d1 improving the position of
the king and here f5 is a nice idea if
white actually captures it then you can
get the night away from from your past
pawn but if f5 you can just play Knight
back to d2 and there are no tricks there
so here we have night the Knights to a
four by black and here comes Knight to
d5 going after the pawn with f5 now 9th
to d2 and here
b3 with E 4 now white wants to create a
passed pawn of his own F captures on e
4f captures on e4 and now King to f7 we
have g4 and night the c5 now going well
pressuring the pawn here with Knights to
be for sorry night to before and now
comes King to e6 and here King to c1
pressuring the rook nights the a for
defending the rook and now g5 a very
important idea you have to create a wall
against the black King using your two
pawns
that are 1 1 square apart with King back
to e7 and now Knight to c6 check with
King to f7 and knights to d4
now both Knights are attacking the pawn
here and there there is no good way to
defend it
we have kinked the g6 going after the
pawn and mountain night for captures on
b3 and here you could capture on g5 but
if you capture on g5 it's all the same
you get a knight c5 now if you capture
you lose the rook so you have to play ok
- now you just trade and I will get this
position which is of course completely
drawn we have a knife for capture son b3
now comes rook to a2
and now comes Knight to f3 defending the
pawn here Knight to c3 with Knight B to
d2 and here on and said ok I'm out of
the exchange but you have to - passed
pawns it's time to end this and played
rook capture son b2 we have King capture
Sundy - sorry King capture son b2 and
now comes Knight captures on e4 with
check King to e3 and after Knight
captures and g5 it was in this position
well not after Knight captures and g5
but after Knight captures and g5 the
players agree to a draw or otherwise it
the players are not allowed to agree to
draws it is a draw by insufficient
material after Keane captures here which
is something I misspoke in the previous
video I said that they were playing
moves for you know for fun or maybe to
give your opponent as much you know as
much opportunity as you can for him to
make a mistake but it was in fact that
they had to play it out
- to - to eat or a stalemate or drove
way insufficient material or anything
like that so a very nice game and this
is the second game in a row where Anand
had had a winning position where he
couldn't grab the full point and he
really prepared a very nice line for
Dean but if he only prepared it a move
further to find that night to the c-4
then he would grab a full point and take
the lead in the 2019 single Cup after
round 7 for those of you who are
interested all of the
games were drawn as well I still haven't
seen them if there are any other
interesting games do suggest them I will
go through them you know if I see them
you know interesting to show I will show
them but you know it's always easier if
you suggest them so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank David MIT's montage car PR
submitter volatility in my York and the
debug but for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos you're thinking for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the singled
cup continuing the capablanca saga and
of course checking up on your
suggestions thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
Sunday